hey youtubers it's Charlie so all the
Justice League actors have been teasing
some stuff from each of their characters
for the film Henry Cavill naturally not
to be left out
tease his black costume from the return
of Superman arc in the comics so this is
going to be a breakdown of that
so what are you looking at here well it just
looks like the under armour tight
costume that zod was wearing during man
of steel but you know obviously you get
the reference to the return of Superman
after the death of superman arc because
Superman died during the end of Batman V
Superman but we know that he's coming
back to life like that was the whole
reason for seen get hit with that
nuclear missile blasts like he turns
into this corpse and space gets hit with
the sun's rays and then booms
regenerates right back
so what is still question as to whether
or not someone digs up his body and then
it gets hit with sunlight comes back or
if like the solar radiation is just like
slowly seeping through the soil and a
very very slow rate just making his
regeneration take longer
he will regenerate in come back but we
didn't really see I don't think we
actually did see what garb he was buried
in but you can see just the level of
detail they go in with these costumes
like this is just the beginning this is
like a small tease of it the Kryptonian
costumes from the beginning a man of
steel give you a better idea for that
just very elaborate very alien looking
but if you're wondering what the color
actually is it's much closer to the
color of Zod's costume so you can you
can think of it as like the black
superman returns costume which is not
the last time that he's worn a black
costume in the comics so if you remember
during the new 52 Andy Diggle tried to
do a run of action comics where he
wanted to chop Superman's arm off people
were like hard pass not gonna let it fly
bro they tease the black costume during
that run there's even this picture here
where he's flying it like he looks super
hardcore kind of evil-looking it was
part of that aborted run that they later
repurposed as part of the lois and clark
rerun when dan jurgens came back on
after conversions so in the last year
there's been a lot of crazy stuff
happening with the Superman character in
the comics I know there's been a lot of
confusion so there's like a chinese
version of superman superman from new 52
is supposedly died the post-crisis
Superman has come back he has a child
with Lois Lane they're still married
they're like
happy family but he's been hiding this
whole time the new 52 has been going on
so there's a lot of confusion with
what's going on with the Superman
character
don't worry about it you don't need to
read any of the comics to understand
what's going on with the movies but i
would recommend just for fun that you go
back and read that return of Superman
arc it's a very different type of
Superman like you can see the way he's
written here he sounds more like a
Marvel character Superman but with guns
is very nineties take it was just meant
to refresh the character like Oh will
kill him off we'll bring him back he'll
be a whole different person
he will be your dad's version of
superman he actually split off into a
later arc where he looks like he's drawn
by rob liefeld look at all these pouches
this was actually from an arc when
Superman went on a space hunt so it just
is funny to see all the different
changes in the characters over to the
same thing for all comic book characters
but there have been a couple times where
he's worn a black costume in the comics
the only 1i think the movie will
reference though is the return of
Superman following the death of superman
arc but as you can see like right around
comic-con they drop this picture of the
Justice League
obviously this is a photoshop job all
these actors weren't standing next to
each other on screen
it's a bunch of different pictures
cobbled together but it's an official
artist's rendering of what the Justice
League will look like in the movies like
Warner Brothers release this but this is
what Superman's costume is going to look
like when he puts on the classic blue
costume but for a brief period it just
seems like they're teasing he's going to
be wearing that black Kryptonian garb
here's the big question though when he
comes back
do you think he will have grown a beard
because I know a lot of you've been
making jokes about mullet Superman which
was the haircut that he came back with
during the return of Superman it was the
beginning of mullet era Superman they
were using the whole arc as a way to
refresh the character design so he went
on to have a mullet for a while before
they cut the hair short again this is
Superman pre casket let me know if you
think they're gonna bring him back with
with like overgrown hair and a beard
because his hair still grows like a
normal person's would but because he's
so strong he can only cut it with his
own heat vision
if you ever wondered how Superman cuts
his hair he does it with the mirror and
very careful use of his heat vision but
in the context to the movies there are
two other things that we know of that
can cut emphasize the Kryptonian spear
Wonder Woman's sword is capable of
piercing
skin and 2 Aquaman's trident but i
wouldn't be surprised if the minute that
he comes back the first time you see him
on screen again he has grown something
of a beard
this is what he looks like in the man of
steel movie so he actually looks pretty
good with the beard on
so while i'm not really expecting him to
resurface to like the third act of the
fit like it's gonna be awhile like we're
probably going to meet the villains
before we meet Superman again so like
something really crazy happens the
Justice League comes together get their
asses handed to them then boom the
ringer gets kicked back into the game
and they take down Steppenwolf in a way
that teases that something even worse
might be coming like dark side for
future sequel
so we go from regenerating Superman two
super beard in the black costume to
Superman back in the blue you know maybe
slightly tweaked version of the costume
it does seem like there's going to be a
slight evolution of all the costumes
just like a little bit because they
tease that the Batmobile like that man
will react to the threat that's coming
and realized that he has to adapt so he
just cranks everything to 11 so spoilers
for Suicide Squad set to talk about that
movie just a little bit so here we go
so the flash appear during Suicide Squad
and it looked like he had the costumes
that he's wearing the Justice League
trailer so they've been teasing that
batman because Bruce Wayne he has
billions of dollars is going to be
funding this team meaning that most of
his upgrades will come via waynetech I
wouldn't be surprised if STAR Labs got
involved too because mother box cyborg
way more advanced that anything that
Wayne Tech has their hands on it because
we're talking about Superman Kryptonian
technology would not be crazy if it's
some point in the movie you know some
point in the far future we get to the
actual watched our satellite and it ends
up being like this hybrid of waynetech
in Kryptonian technology because we've
already seen that Lex Luthor was able to
interface with the Kryptonian ship so
it's not too far for each to say that at
some point they'll find some Kryptonian
tech and use that to build a really
badass base in outer space but again i'm
not expecting to see the watchtower in
the movies anytime soon at least to
like the second maybe even third Justice
League film so any special base that
they will have for the meantime we'll be
the Batcave like when we see Wonder
Woman and Batman joking in the Justice
League trailer there in the
that cave so just continue to use the
Batcave for the meantime but if you guys
didn't see my last video I talked about
the punisher season one they just
confirmed that it's going to be dropping
in 2017 so i'll be doing a video about
that next James Gunn was also teasing
that he's been offered a lot of DC films
and declined so I'll talk about those
too
he also said there were a couple DC
movies that he didn't want to make so
all that stuff's coming next be sure to
subscribe to get it there is a new round
of the give way to all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video will be some more
TV show flash stuff happening this week
too i'm expecting a couple more TV
trailers in the next couple weeks while
you guys wait for that suppose we may
have found cable for the Deadpool and
cable sequel movie that they're making
you can click here to learn all about
that and you can click here for all my
other Justice League videos
thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight